i finished odd tech she was good i liked
it yeah nice very fun show i don't know
how they're going to make a movie
oh yeah they are making a movie are they
yeah i was i was surprised when they
announced that they were making a movie
just because
it felt like it just wrapped everything
up yeah i was like we're done aren't we
yeah also it weirdly seemed like i
didn't think it was as popular on the
surface as you watched she made it out
to be i i watched it yeah i ended up
watching it yeah yeah
have we never talked about it i don't
know
wait i thought i told you i finished it
no you
no you didn't no i would remember
because it's so rare
i would remember if you told me you
finished an anime joey what the [ __ ] i
liked it
yeah i liked it it was good but yeah
again like i was surprised not only
because yeah as as you said like the the
show wrapped up nicely where it was like
how are they going to make a movie out
of it but also it's like i don't know i
feel all texture was one of those shows
where like it got really popular from
word of mouth yeah where like
is it like i was like did it really get
that popular to warrant a movie that's
what i don't know how popular it got
because i remember when i made my video
on it i was just like i made it because
no one was talking about it yeah right
at all and i thought it was kind of like
the underdog i mean everyone who watches
it i know likes it yeah yeah yeah but
that's the thing it's like it's one of
those shows where like i feel you start
watching it because someone who gave it
a go was like it was really [ __ ] good
yeah i feel like it had a similar arc to
a maiden abyss because when made an
abyss came out it just no one was
watching made in abyss at all because
everyone saw the art style and everyone
was just like oh this is children's show
children's show which couldn't be more
further from the truth honestly um but
then like there's a lot of children in
the show
i mean yeah it is a children's show in
some sense yeah that's one for the kids
one for the whole thing they can relate
the children
the children can relate
which is uh
um but yeah i mean like
it kind of like that was another show
that really spread through word of mouth
and then eventually like one like anime
of the year the year it came out yeah uh
odd taxi i feel had a similar thing
where it didn't really have much
promotion or anything like that at least
not not that i could see outside of
japan in japan it actually had some
kind of decent promotion because every
time i remember when it was airing every
time you go in a taxi they would have an
odd taxi
advertisement
yeah yeah did you not see no i didn't
like they always have it like playing um
in like you know the little tvs that i
have on
the taxis
yeah at least i did i saw them i think i
didn't go on enough taxis
did we
did i talk about tokyo avengers i
watched that
i think you have not talked about tokyo
maybe not maybe not an episode well i
was kind of trying to watch all the
animes of the year that were nominated
um when did you get time to launch anime
just go i mean an episode here and there
it's very sporadic right um i was like
oh sunny boy looks
kind of [ __ ] i i didn't yeah you're not
going to enjoy signing i looked at it
and i was like oh yeah it's for those
anime fans that think that they're
really intelligent and want something
deep
category of shows
and to me i took one look at sunny boy
and i was like oh this is what [ __ ]
reddit anime fans are gonna be like this
this is the best anime of the year
actually
if i i i listened to two soundtrack
songs from it and i was like okay if the
soundtrack is as good as the actual show
i think i'm going to enjoy this i just
can't i just cannot stand shows right i
feel like people like it just to be
pretentious right and that's like one of
those shows that like i felt like the
fans make me want to not watch it and
despise it more than the show yeah i get
that yeah i mean like i
i don't even know if i enjoyed sunny boy
uh it's it's a really [ __ ] weird show
and it left an impression on me whether
i enjoyed it or not oh that sounds like
something
yeah i i watched it and i'm just like
this is such a joey show and then like
did you give it out of 10. i don't even
[ __ ] know like
to me it's still like to me like to me
like it's still sinking in it could be
like it's it's one of those mean what
does it [ __ ] mean
what is it okay
i got the perfect analogy did have you
watched like donnie darko yeah what did
you think of it i like time darko what
did you like about it
oh it's been so long exactly
i remember i liked it it's been a very
long time since i watched aniaka yeah
like one of my favorite movies
okay so it's kind of like can you watch
it so then i don't feel bad about
[ __ ] on it because right now i just
feel like i'm [ __ ] into the void
it's like it's like
yeah it's like 86 when i [ __ ] on 86 i
thought no one's going to contest me on
this
meanwhile the entire internet was really
[ __ ] angry yeah i didn't like it but
to be fair i watched that episode of
that it was boring as [ __ ] yeah that's
86 his fault sunny boy is just 12.
sunday boys just 12 episodes um it's
like what actually like because i
remember watching the first three
episodes of sunny boy i thought it was
boring as [ __ ] i thought it was like
boring as [ __ ] this is like if you this
is like this is like holy [ __ ] i'm gonna
be like this is like [ __ ] art house
[ __ ] pretentious [ __ ] um and then
like the soundtrack got recommended to
me and i'm just like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah this soundtrack just like is
everything i want it's like a lot of
soft frog alternative rock in the
soundtrack yeah yeah you listen to some
tracks and i'm just like i kind of want
to watch this show just because yeah
right i found it because i was buying a
bunch of vinyls and yeah on the front
page of the store that the online store
that i go to buy my vinyls it just would
not leave the front page and i was like
what is this
sunny boy thing so i went onto youtube
real quick looked up one song and i was
like yep sold yeah right yeah right and
that's like the best thing i could say
is like the soundtrack just sets the
vibe of the anime okay yeah where it's
less about the plot points and it's more
about the feeling that it gives you did
you end up finishing it oh yeah i did it
i'm finishing it um i mean like i i
finished it and i didn't know what to
think about it but i like i knew like
some of the ideas presented in sunny boy
which is kind of like it's one of those
shows that
you don't know exactly what you think
immediately but
the like i i just remember some scenes
so it's kind of like fully cooling in
that sense yeah yeah kind of kind of
like fully cool right right where it's
just like fully coolly donny darker that
kind of thing where you're watching
you're like i don't really know what i
watched but some parts of it just really
stick with you and just refuse to leave
right that's how i feel with sunnyboy
yeah
do you think it deserved to be nominated
for an anime of the year i don't think
it deserved to be nominated for anime of
the year didn't it win like the reddit
one though like the reddit yeah yeah of
course it did no no
it won that house pretentious type of
action one the reddits not not the user
not the user award
the critical award oh my god
which doesn't help which does not help
its uh image at all yeah the reddit
armchair critics uh gave it the the
award for like anime you know i hate
bashing on low-hanging fruit but yeah i
mean that is sometimes normally the
indication like
yeah i mean like whenever i say like
donnie dog is one of my favorite movies
i'm i'm waiting for it like i'm like
dangling the low hanging fruit it's
normally joking he's normally that guy
yeah in our podcast he's like the
pretentious
did you like it immediately no yeah no i
i only liked it maybe after like my
second or third viewing so young when i
watched it yeah yeah exactly yeah that
was the problem like when i first
watched it i was like maybe like
13 14 years old right and when you watch
when you watch those kinds of movies at
13 14 you don't know what the [ __ ]
going on all you think is oh creepy
bunny wow yeah but then i watched it
again when i was like 17 18 which is
like the peak of pretentiousness of when
it comes to consuming meat i definitely
had that face
yeah do you understand donnie darko
only after i watched like a [ __ ] load of
like analysis videos on it right uh but
like i had i had a friend who
recommended me donnie darko during like
high school or like middle school
who was like a massive fan of it so like
he would tell me like his theories
on it and we would kind of like bounce
off ideas and i'm like i found that i
think that's the reason why i like a lot
of those kinds of media because it's
like especially when you have another
person or like a group of people like
discuss it and like kind of like
theorize and hypothesize like oh this
might be this or this might be that
whatever right like that's kind of fun
um and then you know once you actually
like sit down and like read into what
it's actually about according to the
creator or whatever then you just
realize oh it's not as deep as all these
[ __ ] pretentious
critics made it out to be my favorite
thing is when uh people like speculate
about media and stuff and then the
creator was like no that's not it and
then they're like no no no no i don't
think you i don't think you understood
what you did i think it's actually this
shirt that's literally the evangelist
it's literally like no
no no i'm not lillian
my theory is right please uh yeah i mean
yeah i i i think there's anime that
don't appeal to me as much unfortunately
yeah no and i totally don't blame you no
like it doesn't even appeal to me it's
just like i i had to be i have to be
like
in a really specific mood that comes
along once a year or once every two
years where i'm just like i just want to
watch something and just not understand
it and make me feel things that i mean
the thing i like about this podcast is
that
the viewers can like align their
who they trust's opinion on the show
based on what type of media they like
right so if you if you get if you're
like more to me i'm like and i'm like i
don't like 86 and i'm like you shouldn't
then trust my opinion for other anime
right yeah because like that's like that
show weirdly is like people are obsessed
with it
and i just didn't enjoy it and i didn't
know anything about the series i didn't
know anyone was talking about it yeah i
just didn't like it yeah but i i think
it's like i think part of being a good
critic uh at least or like or talk like
on the online at least or part of being
a good critic is acknowledging that you
have taste because yeah look at like
people who talk about media online and
they should be like you should be able
to judge every single piece of media
objectively equally you know you could
you should be able to be able to judge
them with no bias and i'm just like
that's completely [ __ ] yeah like
like you're not a [ __ ] robot yeah
like when i look at you know for example
like donkey for example when i look at
one of his video game reviews i know
exactly what his taste is yeah and that
gives me a better perspective than a lot
of [ __ ] ign reviewers right yeah
because at least one when donkey like i
think recently like i saw his review of
like horizon forbidden west and like he
like he didn't like
he's completely he he gave his [ __ ] on
okay he like he's shattered i'm not not
completely like compared to some jrpgs
yeah yeah yeah yeah but like i i saw his
criticisms and i was just like wow that
this is like i can completely understand
why he feels this way yeah and i ca and
like but me knowing what kind of gaming
game
i understand and that gives me a better
perspective of what this game is like
compared to a lot of other critics yeah
i would say like the best critics online
are the ones where you continue to keep
watching even though you disagree with
most of their opinions yeah just because
like they because their opinion holds
like even though you don't agree with it
they explain it and they're articulate
enough and they're honest enough with
what they like and the fact that you
know there's no way to completely get
rid of bias with anything and they own
that and you're like well you know i i
knew before coming into this review that
you were probably going to think a
certain way about it and i might not
agree with it but i respect the fact
that you can still stick to this yeah
because it's just like probably
everything i like in the game connor's
going to complain about exactly it's
just like i you know and vice versa yeah
yeah and and vice versa you know but
that just comes with our taste and games
yeah and that's fine it's the same could
be said about anime and stuff yeah i
think i cut you off there no no no no
avengers is okay i really like the first
half and then it got really [ __ ]
and now he's going to have tokyo
revenge's fans on his throat tucker
avengers was
like i saw the first four episodes and
i'm just like this is a read the manga
show like i definitely felt that you
know what i mean like like
there's like a fight at the end have you
watched all of any anyone watched all of
it here
i i watched the first like two episodes
there's um there's this fight that goes
on for like nine or [ __ ] nine or
eight episodes at the end
and it is like the dumbest fight i've
ever seen in my life that sounds like
some eyes and [ __ ] dude it's like it's
like
it's like just constantly it is
literally the fight of wait there's more
yeah
something happens wait there's more yeah
wait there's more and it's like this is
stupid just just [ __ ] resolve it this
is ridiculous this isn't dragon ball
it's like every dragon
this story has been somewhat concise
yeah they drag on a little bit here and
there yeah they have had some long
fights but never more than four or five
episodes i think
it was just it just felt like this last
fight in particular just took the
absolute piss yeah to the point where i
was like this is just stupid yeah and
yeah i had a good cliffhanger but like
the the last i was so bored for like
four episodes but it doesn't matter man
all the characters are hot as [ __ ] but
like according to the fan base
characters and like yeah i like some of
the characters in the show but
my god are so many of them insufferable
and like i i just oh god i mean i like
the show i thought it was good but [ __ ]
man i felt like it like
it like blew its load and then it just
like is it even over is it even over no
it's not over
and i feel like where they left it was
pretty good and it might it might pick
up but like
it just felt like every single time
something happened it was like oh my god
there's more oh my god there's more i
don't know like i know this is gonna
sound really unfair this is totally my
bias but like i i think i only managed
to make it through like the first two or
three episodes because i immediately saw
what
kind of theming they were going for with
the story you know like just like a
bunch of dudes just like you know
fighting you know
it's just weird as well good stuff but i
in my i hate the fact that the moment i
knew where the story was heading in my
head i was immediately just like
i'd just rather read bucky to be honest